Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast from my day,
May 25th,
2015 the final Monday that there will ever be in May of 2015.
Let me ask you,
let me ask you,
what are you gonna do about it?
Huh?
You ain't doing shit today,
are you?
I don't hear a fucking word out of anybody if this podcast,
if you consider it late,
you,
self-involved jackass.
If you consider it late,
you got the day off anyways,
don't ya?
Well,
if you don't,
you have a shit job or your work for yourself because when you work for
yourself,
you fucking money never sleeps or whatever dumb shit they say in some fucking
hip hop songs.
You know what I mean?
I hate,
I'll fucking dramatic.
They try to make every Goddamn fucking moment,
you know,
not all rappers,
but just in general money,
never sleep.
More money,
more problems.
Not really.
Not if you would just move away from the toxic element that you grew up in.
You know,
if he'd start buying some uh,
uh,
some assets,
if he had your money,
make money,
then you don't have them.
You don't have more problems.
Stay out of the club.
You have enough fucking money to,
to bring some bitches over to your house you don't want and you don't need that
go out.
Yeah.
Know you're just fucking let me give a little fucking old white guy to rapper
discussion here.
Just fucking once you make your money,
get the fuck out of there and don't listen to those assholes all.
Yeah.
You forgot where you came from?
No.
I remember where it came from.
That's what you don't see is what you don't understand.
I remember exactly where I came from.
All right.
You want me to come back?
I'll come back during the day when all you maniacs is still sleeping,
not coming back at night.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
You come back during the day,
come back at like 10 in the morning.
If you want to make a fucking positive impact,
come back at 10 in the morning.
You know when the good people are getting up.
Right.
You know,
watching their kids,
you know,
you already went to work or whatever.
That's the deal.
But that's second shift comes in.
That's when you get the fuck out.
I,
that's what I would do.
I don't know.
I mean,
that exists at all levels.
You know what I mean?
What to you?
Some fucking,
yeah,
just some jackass from the suburbs.
You know what you gotta do?
You gotta get out of it.
You've got to get out of the time.
Whatever town you're from with is still wearing the football.
Jacket's going down to the water and whole.
Right.
Yo
uh,
no,
I don't think I'm too good for you.
I take up too good for this.
I'd like a little more than this if you don't mind.
That's all you got to do.
You just,
you just fucking,
you fucking have a bar in your house.
That's what you do.
Right?
And then what you do is you invite your friends over your friends,
people you know.
Okay.
Then if you want some horrors or whatever,
you have them come over.
He flipped on the security camera until there's no fuck.
And he said,
she said,
right,
you give the pimp a little fucking throat coat tea or whatever and his fucking
Sas Barilla,
whatever the fuck he wants to drink.
You have a nice evening.
Everybody goes home,
think bang,
boom,
done.
You need to do all of that.
And you Cabana,
you don't have them in your real house.
That's what you do.
And I'll fucking go back down in the seat.
God Damn.
What's wrong with you?
What are you doing?
What am I talking about?
I Dunno.
Audition out advice like I have any business giving anybody advice.
You know what?
I have a bar in my house.
You know,
it's just been a bunch of bottles laying around,
you know,
I'm fucking,
take a bite out of him every fucking God damn day.
You know what?
I'm at my heaviest I've ever been.
I've been talking to you guys,
sing in the gym song and all that.
You know what?
That southern tour and then the 19 shows and then I got sick and then I fucking
Jew.
He kept eating like an animal and I'm at my heaviest.
I've been in fucking six years and I'll tell you right now,
I'm disgusted with myself.
Oh,
belly fat again.
Billy red velvet.
Oh Man,
what did I do?
Uh,
Jesus,
I got to fuck.
You know what I did?
I did everything I tell you guys not to do.
I did.
And then,
um,
I had a flight yesterday,
so I do weight and balance.
So I had to get on the fucking scale and I got on with my clothes and it said
one 90.
You know what?
I weighed myself this morning.
I was one 86 without fucking shoes and cell phones and all that shit.
But,
uh,
God,
I'm so disgusted with myself.
I need to lose 15 fucking pounds,
15 fucking pounds.
So what did I do?
I did the usual,
oh,
fuck this.
Fuck the shop getting in shape.
You know,
when you do that and fucking lasts for about 12 hours.
So I'm about 12 hours in after I weighed myself.
I was so fucking disgusted.
He had a good lesson though.
And then,
uh,
I came home and I finished off the salad with salmon.
And then for dinner I had a fucking black bean burger,
no bun with a side salad,
you know,
ah,
crushed me to order that.
And then,
but now I gotta tell you after I ate it,
I felt great,
felt great,
and I drank waters the rest of the night and to figure it out,
right.
You know,
with clothes on everything in one 90.
So I'm probably about one 85,
one 86 eating like this.
I'll wake up in the morning,
I'll probably be about one 84,
right?
Woke up in the morning,
one 86.8 I'm a fat freckled fuck right now.
I'm a fucking flounder.
I don't like it.
I'm not even a button down shape right now.
You know that when your buttons get to fucking,
they start having a fucking,
you know that that stress mark,
uh,
sides of the shirt is,
it's holding it together.
I think he's doing a joke about that.
Mac with a button was like an I or doing the iron cross,
trying to hold both sides together.
It's fucking horrible.
It's absolutely horrible.
So I dunno,
I ate my way into it.
I got to eat my way out of it cause I don't really have time to fucking go to
nuts.
I did take my dog on a two hour hike today,
but,
um,
I don't know what an asshole.
You don't,
you don't really fuck me.
Sent me,
I've been off the rails on and off the rail since November or October when I
started,
uh,
sat in the writer's room.
F is for family and I started working eight hours a day and we started ordering
lunch and all that type of shit and I felt myself putting it on like five
pounds.
Then I held the five pounds in the right to the fucking holidays through on
another three.
And then somewhere,
I don't know,
in March,
I started going back to the gym after I was back.
I was up till I was like [inaudible] 72 before this shit star.
Then I will fuck went up into the one eighties again.
Then it was coming down to like one 79 and then the southern tour came out the
other fucking side of it at ward 86.
I mean,
I guess that's not bad against six bucks,
seven pounds.
Ah,
fucking worst.
Every time I go to set up,
I feel like I'm fucking got a kid as a kid grown in me,
a little fat fucking kid.
Um,
anyways,
so last night I stayed in for the first night since I can even fucking remember
I didn't drink.
You know,
I always have a couple of drinks.
I'm not going to lie to you.
There's no reason for me not to.
I don't have any children.
All right.
You'd be doing it too.
Don't judge me.
So last night I'm staying in,
you know,
took my dog for a walk around the block,
staring down at my stomach,
fucking looking at myself in the mirror.
Go and look at you fat shaming myself.
Look what you did.
Look at you.
You're a fucking mess,
right?
Awful fucking awful.
Right?
So,
you know what's even worse was I continued to fucking lift weights as I put on
all this weight.
So now I look like that classic fucking,
uh,
you know,
the only thing I'm missing,
this is like,
you know what,
that guy that keeps fucking working out,
but he keeps eating like an asshole.
So he's got the pecs and the shoulders and he's just got that fucking awful gut
right?
And then he's got the tight button down and you just see the fucking shirts
struggling every time the guy fucking reaches over to grab another potato skin.
That's the kind of fucking shape I'm in right now.
Um,
so anyway,
so I stayed in last night and uh,
I just watched TV,
you know,
which is always good when you're trying to drop weight,
whatever.
I didn't fucking drink,
go fuck yourself.
So,
uh,
I watched that you watch that rich kids of Beverly Hills.
It's fucking unbelievable.
It's just one of those things.
My wife tapes a bunch of Shit,
you know,
if for some fucking reason,
she's always telling me she doesn't delete my shit.
But whenever I come off the road,
all my shows,
you know,
fast and loud,
where's all the fast and loud?
Where's all,
hey,
where's all the fast and loud?
You know,
I yelled at,
cause I know she's up and she's just like,
oh wow.
I didn't do anything.
Really.
It's not recording the series anymore.
How does that happen?
If I hit record series and then I go on the road and I leave,
what happened?
Are you going to tell me it was a malfunction?
How come whatever it malfunctions the,
the,
the dead DV.
Why does it always malfunction on the shit I want to record,
you know,
I don't fucking know.
So anyways,
so I'm like,
all right,
any port in a storm?
I watched the rest of that show.
The comedians,
one of my favorite new shows that in last man on earth of course.
Um,
so great to see Billy crystal again.
You know,
such a big fan.
He is,
man.
He's fucking hilarious on that show.
And,
uh,
I don't know if you guys have seen the show.
I just love how Josh gads character has no idea all the accomplishments that
Billy crystal is,
uh,
has gotten over the years.
It,
it'd be like,
yeah,
you know,
I'm up for a kid's choice of work and can you believe that?
Can you believe it?
And he's like,
yeah,
I'm up for one too.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He goes,
yeah,
yeah.
He goes,
I've won that.
I've won one of those.
He just really,
I,
I know it.
I just love that he has no fuck.
That's so,
such like a sobering thing in this fucking,
I guess in life in general is where you're going to accomplish all this shit.
You just think you're going to be the fucking man and you just don't understand
that there's a whole generations of kids that are coming up that could give a
fuck,
which is why
if you make money,
at some point you got to become a lender,
Lord.
Oh,
I'm on my way.
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to fucking do it.
I always said I was never going to do it,
but I'm going to do it.
I was like,
I don't want to be fucking dealing with fixing toilets and shit.
I'm not going to do,
that'll get someone to manage the building form,
going to buy something.
I got to do it.
That's my,
is it strategy?
Right?
Stead of going out and buying a bunch of Shiny Shit,
right?
Going down to the club and getting in trouble.
No,
you stay at home.
You drink yourself just shy of 200 pounds.
What?
You check out real estate,
that's what you do.
So as you set yourself up financially,
you simultaneously destroy your heart and liver,
right?
And then you stick it all in a will he need give it to your wife and that one
day,
right?
He's sitting there but an egg salad sandwich.
You're down at the track.
Come on,
Yo.
Six said,
next thing you know you're slumped over the rail.
Take a horse tail or the face and it's fucking over.
That's it.
It's over.
But you know what?
Everybody in your life,
his sight,
he was really smart with his money.
Oh Shit.
Thank God.
Thank God God bless him.
You know he died doing what he loved doing what he loves.
Screaming at the horses with a 0.3 blood alcohol level,
having a massive coronary.
That's what he liked to do.
Do you know he had seven heart yet?
Seven,
seven.
I wasn't sex.
I thought it was salmon.
You know all the old bitches who never die sitting there on the coffee shop just
chatting away,
right?
Burning calories running their fucking yaps.
They live.
They live forever.
That's what fucking kills me.
All these broads going on TV,
bitch moaning and complaining.
We now get this and we don't get that.
You fucking live forever.
Hey,
look who's here.
Wow,
you look fucking amazing possible for you to do the podcast and not scream at
the top of your fucking lungs.
Is it possible for you to do that?
You're too good to be true.
Can't take my eyes framing my name just a second ago.
Why were you screaming?
Cause I wanted you to come up here.
You dummy.
I know,
but you can do it in a little bit more of a positive way and not call me a dummy
as well.
What's the,
it's quite all right.
Pull up a fucking chair.
Pull up a chair and grab a microphone.
You asshole.
And I want to,
I want you to explain to me your,
you,
you have limited time on this podcast today because
fucking look at me like that.
All right.
Listen,
don't get a fucking chair.
Why don't you have a chair in here?
This office is a disgrace.
It's a disgrace as my fucking torso.
One 86.8 and year.
That's what you're banging a big fucking flounder.
I'm getting older.
I'm getting,
I'm rapidly approaching.
Get on top.
Get on top weight.
Oh God.
You Still gonna love me Mia.
When that brow sweat is raining down on you like the fucking Goddamn,
I don't know.
Something about the rain forest would have flux.
The microphone.
So we put a cap on both of our weight.
You look great.
Thank you.
What the fuck is my,
uh,
there's,
there's a,
there's another mic in,
in the,
uh,
in the thing there.
Can't stop eating like a pig.
He's a fat freckled.
Fuck I fucking hate myself right now.
Yeah.
Hey,
good.
Put the,
put the windscreen on Jesus Christ.
God Damn fucking.
Here we go.
Setting up the microphone.
Ladies and gentlemen,
coming to the podcast.
Oh my God.
There you go.
How's this?
That's very good.
Now I want to know something near.
Okay.
You're adorable.
You're beautiful.
Even when you snore,
it's cute as opposed to me.
Right?
Let me ask you this.
How would I go on the road is fast and loud.
Yeah.
I series
recorded.
We've made that point like nine times.
I just want people to be clear that this is just a thing that you do.
I rag,
I did that.
So I can have you come up here.
All right.
And I gotta tell you something else.
And yet this screaming that I do that puts Froot loops on the table.
Oh my God.
I knew that's where you were going.
Why?
Because of your screaming.
That's right.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I got it.
They love it.
I know,
but we are not every time.
We are not retired.
I am not an audience.
I don't need you to be screaming like your life.
It need a nice favor for the stage.
So we'd had saved before the fucking stage.
Every time you sit down and eat a nice crunchy cereal,
you gotta say to yourself,
thank God my husband screams like a lunatic.
Right?
Ah.
So what are you talking about?
Fast and loud?
I told you I don't know what happened.
Yeah.
Okay.
Don't point your finger at me while you sitting there giving me shit about
screaming and yelling last night.
I'm trying to go to bed.
And You have watching that Frankie Valli musical.
Yeah.
And I'm trying to sleep every fucking five seconds.
You were asleep though.
Shit,
I can't do it.
You already kind of have a higher pitched voice,
so it's actually not hard for you to go into that register.
That wasn't bad.
Listen,
don't compliment me because you're watching your fucking TV.
After that shoe was better on stage then it wasn't a movie virgin.
It looked great.
Well,
thank you.
Mimi Ebert.
Who?
Who in God's name would care what you think about a fucking movie?
Why do you have me up here then if you're just going to be an asshole to me,
I thought,
Oh God,
what is wrong with this is how I say I love you.
I know why.
Why did no one forever a seventh grade boy pulling pigtail?
Shut your face.
Why?
Why does fast and loud not record it?
This is like the ninth time I have asked.
I know you've asked me nine times and I'm answering your nine times.
I don't know.
I don't know why I haven't erased.
It's interesting.
I take games and I come back and the games that you don't,
what happens is you're sitting here and you're taping two things at once,
right?
Our DVR has the capability to take five things at once and I've never taped five
things at once,
so even if I did have two things going on at once,
you're,
I don't know.
It's all my stuff.
Bill,
I don't know.
Is there anything worse than when you think you think you have them?
I thought we still had the old school ones.
Well,
back in the day,
well,
when you recorded two things at what used to race my shit all the time.
So I'm yelling at you about that.
What did I use?
Arrays of yours all the time.
Every fucking game.
And you always go,
oh,
could you Rudy booze dough for the DVR.
It's all my stuff.
And meanwhile,
every bowl on the DVI
never comment on the DVR like forever.
Do you need to have it all but you don't even go back and watch it.
We talking about how do you,
how many know right though?
Have you gone back and watched it?
Yeah,
I've that Superbowl three times
and I loved it more each time we watched it and we rate Superbowl great teams
and two great coaches.
I love conversation about sports with you,
although wait,
whoa,
whoa.
Hey,
hey,
easy.
You walked into my restaurant.
Not the other way around.
You ask you what's on the menu.
It's on the menu.
You don't like it.
Fucking take a hike lady.
Do you know who you like Justin James Number 99 from the uh,
yeah.
You don't have the right name.
That sounds like a guy.
You follow bills.
Wait,
Justin James?
Yup.
He sounds like he fucking build hot rods.
You're thinking Jesse James.
He's the one he was on that.
Wait,
I'm going to look it up.
He is the one,
I was just stressing that timber lake.
No,
I was outside your element.
I was just looking at an Instagram.
I've hairs cause he was showing a picture.
That's why you're so pretty.
He was um,
yeah,
there's a big scar on his thigh or something.
What was his name?
I don't know Leah.
Anyway.
Oh Jesus.
So why did you have makeup more up here?
Cause I was giving you shit about,
I'll get to it.
I'm looking at the lounge,
my fucking show and I like seeing how they do.
I know,
but I don't know what happened to it.
And you can also go online because they have everything online now.
I don't do that.
You don't do that?
I oh,
I'm sorry.
Was that not you?
Why watching people slap fight each other on youtube.
Yeah,
that's what I get.
An hour and a half.
I'm not gonna Watch it for a,
for a quality piece of entertainment.
Someone wants to slap somebody in the face.
They are funny.
Was that that that lady,
the big fat lady on the,
on the,
uh,
the tricycle.
Amy,
that's it baby.
She was singing the r Kelly song and then she fucking tips over it and then it's
fucking great.
No,
it was a football player on the cover of the fucking ESPN magazine who played in
the,
Oh wait,
who did we play in the Seattle.
Seattle.
Okay.
Do you realize what you're doing or listeners right there?
Is that when Katy Perry was on,
did the halftime show,
I'm sorry.
I know you hate me right now.
I know so much.
Right?
I believe you got to leave.
You had done hi,
cause that was,
we're not going to answer questions.
No,
that isn't it.
That you want to come back during that go,
go get yourself a fucking egg mcmuffin herself to get me a water.
All right.
Get out of here.
All right,
hold on a minute.
Well,
you taken up time here.
You're taking up time.
Can you hear the serial?
Hey,
this guy.
What guy is this guy?
I don't know who that is.
I know.
I don't know.
Bj.
What?
Oh yeah,
from the Texas.
It's all right.
There you go.
Yeah.
All right.
Shut the dog.
I'll get me some water.
They'll come back.
Jesus Christ.
Yes,
you're right.
I'm a man.
I asked you to do something.
You're a woman.
You go and you do it and you don't ask questions.
Uh,
so anyways,
like I was saying this,
sitting there bitch moaning and complaining about all this stuff don't have,
but
if you know,
and it's like you fucking outlive us.
You outlive us.
What are you giving me?
Water four and a shot glass.
Come on,
Nia.
Don't be a Douche.
Uh,
well,
you know what?
You have a birthday coming up.
I know exactly what I'm getting.
Yeah.
Big Bag of Fritos.
You're an ass hole.
Put it in a juice glass.
Okay.
All right.
So anyways.
Yeah,
so they're always bitch murmuring and complaining about what they don't have.
Right.
You know,
do they have a look around and see what they do?
Have a whole fucking platoon,
his shoes,
the dead guy paid for,
right?
Oh snap.
12 to six right there,
baby.
Yeah.
Aimia do you know why I make more an hour than you?
Because I'm better than you because I'm worth more than you.
Yeah.
Think about it,
Nia.
Think about all the great inventions.
Think about all the great stuff that makes you a life simple.
Has a broad invented one of them.
Has any of them stop running their Yap for more than three seconds to even
invent the fucking can opener.
Okay.
You know what?
That's actually a great question.
Let's go to them broad inventions.org let's see.
Let's see what the ladies,
women,
I'm going to tell you something.
Inventors right now.
Okay?
I'm going to tell what'd you guys invent?
Skippy peanut butter.
Marie Curie.
Huh?
You know what?
Your Mike's turned down for a reason.
All right,
here we go.
Women inventors.
Hmm.
Yeah,
we were so lame.
Famous,
famous.
Fucking lame.
You are with this fucking premise that you have been.
I know,
I know.
I know how bad I am.
Years of your career.
Yeah.
Mike's back on.
You've been squeezing this dumb premise drive for the last 10 years of your
career.
What do you have assignment?
Move on to move on.
What are you having for breakfast?
A nice big bowl of feminism.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what?
That dead fucking chauvinism paid for that bull of feminism.
Famous women inventors.
Oh good.
Are you actually going to learn something and not talk out of your ass?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
This is going to be a quick week.
This can be a quick read.
No,
it's not.
Actually.
Look at all these people here.
There's like 12 names.
You're gonna fall asleep before you get these guys on the clippers in there.
Then there's fucking women offenders.
Mary Anderson.
Barbara asks gins that takes care of the ace.
Patricia billings.
Mary had Donovan's Sally Web box.
Well,
what the fuck do you think I'm serious?
Yes.
Uh,
let's see.
Marianne is anyone who has ever driven in a rain or snow storm.
Really to get a new bet though.
So you got to test.
Do you really need to get a new bed?
What are you talking about?
I,
you know what I'm talking about?
What track?
I didn't trash women watch my last special.
I didn't,
but what's happening right now?
You still come and wait.
Circling the wagon back around to the same guy who I don't feel good.
This is comfort food from it.
Oh,
this is comforting to you.
you know what?
You don't say wait.
So wait,
wait,
wait.
Okay.
Miss Enlightened.
What did,
what did Mary Anderson Event?
I don't know.
I never claim to know.
What did Barbara askings invent?
I don't know.
Post it.
Is that true?
No.
Oh,
how about Patricia billings?
I don't you call yourself a feminist and you don't know you starting lineup.
That's not I,
you want me to name the fucking patriots offensive line cause I'll fucking do it
now.
I really don't.
Sally Fox do anything regarding sports?
Uh,
yeah.
I don't know what it's just because of it.
That doesn't mean that I would know every female,
but that doesn't make any sense.
But you don't know any of them.
Oh,
how bout,
how bout Gary and Med nesmith Graham didn't Marie Curie in bed.
I'm going to name of all the names on this list and I want you to tell me what
one of them did.
Dr Temple Grandin.
Oh yes.
Uh,
she was the woman who invented the thing for cows.
So when they were going to slaughter they wouldn't be freaking out like the sort
of like a little pressurized thing that's on them cause she had like autism or
something like that.
You got some of it.
The thing that usually amazes people about most about prolific woman inventor,
Dr Temple Grandin is not all the great stride she has made to improve animal
handling devices.
You nailed it.
Yeah.
Nor the fact that she earned a phd in animal science.
Why is that amazing?
You know what?
You are such a fucking Douche bag.
You can't give it up even when it's in front of your face and black and white
like I'm,
well I don't like how when you guys,
why wouldn't you guys do shit that we do at suddenly amazing.
You know what?
Goodbye.
You guys drove a garbage truck and you're laying out of a god damn garbage truck
down to the train to be a lifetime movie over and over and over again.
Promises that you've been doing for the last time.
Oh Shit.
You know,
I like it.
Come on.
You're being a baby about this.
I'm not the in a baby.
You're being an aide.
I'm breaking my balls.
You get no fresh down there.
I A,
I know who she is because there was an HBO movie about it starting called.
There you go.
Thank God.
I know your kids sit down and read.
All right.
Really?
Bill,
what was the last book you read and fucking Steven Adler is biography.
Does it count?
I think that might've been the last one.
I read the fairy 2014 book.
Alright,
whatever.
So you know,
so you guys,
you know you could kind of,
nice little list here.
What?
I can't believe you felt the need to go online as it does somehow way did women
invent things?
Like what is wrong with you?
You,
I really had to keep asking that question.
Hey,
is it because you're 46 year old white man from Boston?
Like is it,
can I really just distill it down to your stats?
Can I ask you a question?
You know you can't.
I want you to name some women inventors,
temple Grandin
I keep saying Marie Curie didn't choose you talking all this shit like I can't
believe above blah blah,
blah.
But you don't even have the,
you don't even have the bullets in your gun.
You're over there.
Yep.
You're shooting blanks.
I don't need to have bullets and my,
I know you don't.
All you gotta do is start pitching and everybody listens to you.
I'm smart enough.
You're the one going online like a prehistoric.
Don't blow your nose into the microphone.
Jesus.
How are you still sick anyway?
Hey listen,
cause I'm up all night trying to find something you guys
did.
If anybody takes his fucking seriously,
go fuck yourselves.
You know somebody is going to take a little clip of this and send it to some
clambake fucking site and I'll get in trouble.
Yeah,
whatever the fuck they are.
Oh my God.
Let's just focus.
Let's just focus on the Nigga.
I swear to God,
when I went to India and I saw that Todd that take a ship between two parked
cars at fucking,
I don't in Sab.
Yeah.
I don't want any
plated.
She's sitting there with a brooch.
You wearing a brooch.
That's more than that kid will ever have.
What is your problem?
What are you talking about,
Bro?
Whenever those women get on TV,
start complaining,
they start dressing like fucking Eleanor Roosevelt.
Don't they put on a wool suit?
When's the last time you saw anyone where a brooch that wasn't like,
I thought the people in Canada were wearing it,
but it had to do with World War One veterans.
I thought that was a broach and I've got a bunch of shit about that.
You know,
let's thank you here.
Thankfully the Canadians are very forgiving people.
You know,
if you can have a couple of donuts down at Timmy Ho's and they're fine.
Who Do you like for the Stanley company?
Um,
the Bruins were going to,
oh Geez.
We didn't make the La Kings kings go,
neither one of them.
You're all for two.
Oh,
those La kings getting Wednesday.
We're fun though.
They were.
I did enjoy it.
It was,
wasn't very surprised at how enjoyable it was.
Why we went.
There you go.
You know that if I said the same thing about women inventors,
I'd be a fucking chauvinist.
I don't understand how me going to a hockey game for the first time.
It's like you tending to not no more.
It's called humor.
Oh,
okay.
It's called the joke.
Ha Ha.
Well,
thanks for explaining that bill.
Thank God you're here to explain things.
Things got a man is here to explain things to a woman.
It's okay.
You didn't understand it.
It's okay to not understand things.
Where are the questions for this week's podcast?
I don't think we're up to that point yet.
I don't even have the advertising yet.
Oh,
I was going to say,
have you read your advertising horribly yet?
The Andes.
Every time I make of me,
you're just making fun of yourself.
Why is that?
Because you married me.
You Dope.
I'm married you because I love you.
Okay.
Be Nice to me in the podcast.
All right.
That's it.
Cathy,
can you give me some fucking water on a real glass real glass?
Okay.
I know.
Minimal fucking effort.
You probably want the same amount an hour for this,
right?
That a bus boy would do it.
He bring me a fucking bus boy.
We'll bring over a full glass like,
oh man.
Okay.
All right.
Sweet cakes.
There we go.
Jesus Christ.
Anyways.
Okay.
Nia yet outlive us.
Um,
all right.
Oh,
by the way,
I'm,
I'm performing down at the comedy store.
Ladies.
I'll be done the cow.
It's,
it's still,
it's not fucking long enough.
Oh,
you wanted to write down on a regular glass.
what's it matter?
Do you start thinking about dresses on the way to the kitchen?
Not being an extra duty this week,
but you know what?
I'm enjoying it.
All right.
Um,
I want to be down in the comedy store,
a hosting
and the,
uh,
the main room at eight 30 this Wednesday.
There's only a few tickets left.
And you,
yes,
you could be one of the lucky people to come down and watch the,
uh,
more to love bill bird.
Take the fucking stage.
MMM,
yeah.
At the comedy store at eight 30.
It's an all things comedy show and uh,
it's a powerhouse lineup and all of that type stuff.
And I got a bunch of new bits and I'm really excited about doing and um,
you know,
who was on the show?
Oh,
I don't know.
Fucking Neil Brennan.
Al Madrigal.
Bunch of,
bunch of based,
you know,
what do you want from me?
What do you want from India?
I want you to at jazzy issues.
Yay.
Pointing in society.
The ones that affect me.
Fuck everybody else.
Um,
all right.
Where the hell are we trying to see what the fuck I would just,
I don't even know how to do this Twitter thing.
I'm trying to see where the hell I am.
My thing.
Who gives a fuck anyways?
Yeah.
I don't know who the fuck's on the show.
It's going to be a great show.
Well,
come on down.
How was that?
Was that good?
Also,
people have been asking me,
hey bill,
I really liked some of those posts as you've had on your recent tours.
Are there any leftovers?
Why?
Yes.
Yes,
there are.
The first batch of leftovers and at least things will go fast.
I hope.
Um,
I have,
uh,
some posters leftover from my southern tour,
the Billie Bible belt tour.
And,
uh,
they're all autographed and a,
they make a great gift for somebody.
You don't really give a fuck about.
All my shit does,
you know,
cause it's always 20 bucks.
He got 20 bucks.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Frame it.
Make it fucking night of it.
Just get out of my house.
Um,
those will go on sale on Wednesday.
and then the Boston ones,
we would come in on sale,
I think whenever the fuck I get those back,
I got about a hundred,
so those left.
So anyways,
there we go.
I don't have any,
God damn,
I don't have any reads for this week is a very low whatever.
Everybody's got the day off,
right?
What do I have to try this week?
All right.
I just got myself in all kinds of trouble.
Oh,
here's the live reads.
I got it.
Look who's here?
Everybody.
Bodu boo boo me Andy's beyond these.
No more sweaty balls.
Boop,
boop,
boop.
We undies brds where I'm in a waterfall,
get 'em all away and walk in the sun.
All of a sudden your ass is burning on your bum cause you got some fucking me
undies.
It pulls away the fucking sweat.
Real grows.
You'd have a have sweaty balls.
Get down there ladies and oh
you know something at this point my neighbors are gonna give me shit so I gotta
fucking let's take it down.
90% people,
that's the percent of your life that you're in your underwear and underwear.
It gets old fast.
You know that feeling of putting on old saggy underwear,
you need to know the feeling of putting on great fitting underwear that is two
times softer than cotton and is getting right in your balls face.
You need to know about me undies.com everybody,
me undies has the most comfortable underwear you'll ever try on and it's insane
how good they make you feel.
They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on you and they literally pull moisture away from your skin.
She is stay cool,
but they also make you look great.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and check out the photograph you fucking Weirdo.
And,
and for the ladies,
checkout those smoking hot boy shorts,
right?
But you have to try them on for yourself.
You know what?
This quality would typically retail for two times.
To me,
Andy Price.
I love it.
They throw shit out like that.
What it is that what's going on in the fucking underwear market?
No retail middleman means more savings for you.
Here.
We will make it easy for you.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burn and get 20% off your first order and low
flat rate.
International shipping save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee you're going to be happy with them or your first pair is free.
Once you feel me undies on your body,
you're never going to go back and me undies isn't just for guys.
They just launched their all of me.
Why not take all of me women's collection have these things up again.
She,
Oh uh Ooh.
Ah,
it will feel like our horses muzzle is nozzle in your fucking clam today.
A four piece line of undies designed specifically for the female body in all of
its complex,
gorgeous has held glory.
But to get that 20% off,
you have to go to me undies.
Me undies.
[inaudible] dot com slash burb we'll do,
do,
do me undies.
Uh,
that's me on these m e n d u n d I e s.com/all right.
What do we got next?
Trunk Club?
Everybody.
Hey guys,
you don't like go to the fucking mall.
You might hate shopping,
but you still want to look good,
right?
What have you could snap your fingers and have an illegal alien iron all of your
shit.
No,
I'm kidding.
What have you could snap your fingers and have a trunk full of clothes that fit
perfectly and make you look amazing.
You're gonna love what it gets delivered to you from Trunk club@trunkclub.com
slash bird.
You answer a few simple questions about your look.
I Dunno,
so times I like collars,
but sometimes I don't.
Your style,
your size,
Husky,
and then assign a real person who helps to style you fucking style.
Yeah.
The email,
your list of clothes they recommend sending you,
you approve and at no cost to you.
They send you just a trunk full of Shit,
fresh new clothes to your door.
You try him on,
you keep what you want.
You send back what you don't in their prepaid box.
That's it.
A better wardrobe that you then you could ever pick out for yourself in minutes
did I mentioned that the service is free.
Your stylist,
the shopping,
the box,
even the shipping,
all 100% free when you go to trunk club.com/burr only pay for the clothes you
keep.
Why would think that the stylists and the shipping and all that is rolled into
that price,
isn't it?
Isn't it?
Trunk Club?
No ongoing subscriptions,
no hidden charges,
no malls,
just great clothes.
Handpicked for your style.
You're gonna thank me on this and right now it's completely free.
So get on.
Go on,
go get started today.
You Con Trunk club.com/bird today.
That's trunk club.com/bar hey,
needy.
Come here.
Come in here.
Come in here,
lady.
Boop,
boop,
boop.
Oh,
hold on.
Whoa,
whoa.
All right.
Well I guess I'm going to have to do it.
Yeah.
Oh,
so how about that fucking ducks Blackhawks series?
That's incredible,
Huh?
I was really,
I was really psyched that the Blackhawks won game too.
I mean,
games make it to two.
Sorry,
game four.
Only because I want to see that thing go seven games because uh,
it's just a hockey at the highest level.
And
what is that?
Like this thing that happened to him during some game?
What happened?
Oh,
I was looking at his other leg.
No,
the woman.
Oh,
you're back to two.
Uh,
this is JJ watts.
Yeah.
What happened?
That's a bruise from what?
Getting hit.
Throw it back.
So when this happened in the first half of the bills game,
I dunno,
he slid on something.
I don't know.
I've never played football.
He got hit dude.
His legs looked like these 80.
Anyways,
Nia and my hair.
Listen,
obviously I think a woman should make when a guy makes.
Okay,
but you guys need to let your fucking hair.
Now,
a lot of guys say some dumb shit.
Every once in a while they'll get no fucking employee.
Anybody fucking relax.
I can't wait for you guys to make as much as make.
Maybe once you go into a bar and maybe throw down a fucking c note by around,
how do you know I haven't bought a round of drinks for somebody because I've
known you for 10 years.
They're buying me a drink.
Yeah.
After all I do for you is,
is a fucking joke.
Okay.
You're thrown a nickel into an ocean here.
All right.
What else do I do for you?
I'm talking about when,
when have you ever just walked into a fucking bar,
slam down a fucking scene note and just bought a round of drinks for people
because you have an a great fucking,
yeah.
Have you ever done it?
No,
I don't even,
I don't even know if you ever done that and throw down and see,
you know,
just cause you were having a great fucking day at the a drink.
Some may
like that.
Like that was totally done that to
a speakeasy,
which is never a speakeasy cause it's legal,
but they had its design.
And when we were in,
uh,
in,
in Denver,
me and Jason Lyon,
we go in there,
we're going to go to the Broncos.
Uh,
sounds like the first game of the NFL season.
That'd be weird.
Don't be the money that they won the Superbowl anyway.
Oh cause it was against the Steelers or the n one.
I can't fucking remember whatever went to the bar.
So we go to the box,
I 80 day and um,
oh shut up.
So we go to the bar and they had a,
they had this,
I don't know what the fuck it was,
but it was like 60 years old.
Okay.
All right.
It was,
it was,
I don't know what it was.
Whatever you can have everything else turns to like fucking vinegar.
What was it?
A Cognac,
what?
Couldn't be like 60 years old.
I Dunno.
I don't know.
So what happened was like fucking like 90 bucks a shot.
So I just had a great run of dates and I said,
fuck it.
I said,
La head.
we're doing this.
He goes,
dude,
you can't do that.
I go,
fuck that.
Come on first gave me NFL season.
Who gives a shit?
Governments taking them on money anyway,
so let's do that.
Right?
So the bartender,
I see it,
he goes,
oh my God.
It was like a,
that's like the greatest people at the bar.
Bartenders.
We always,
he's a young kid.
We want to do the shot.
And I said,
all right,
I go and buy a new a shot too.
He goes,
no,
I can't do that.
And whatever his name was,
I was like,
Doug,
yes she can.
So then he said,
all right.
He goes,
this is the thing.
Can I split the shot with two of the other bar backs?
I said,
yeah,
there you go.
There's my hundred bucks through it.
Down we all,
we all took a sip and it was one of the great experiences I've ever had drinking
anything in my fucking life.
So there you go.
Congratulations.
You know what?
That was classic right there.
Females,
female shit.
Well,
you just said,
did you ever do it?
I gave you a fucking example,
and then rather than saying like,
oh,
I stand corrected,
you then say,
I stand corrected.
You're right.
You went in,
you threw it down.
You gave everybody a good time.
Yeah.
Great.
Do you think that's an isolated incident?
I don't know.
There was no,
it wasn't the amount of money that could be in our bank,
the amount of money that could be in our bank account,
but it isn't because I'm such a great fucking guy.
It's ridiculous.
Well,
I'm glad everyone is getting to see what a great guy you are and they're not
completely it on your,
this is what happens when you marry a smarty.
Even when you get them,
they fucking wiggle their way out of it.
All right,
let's get some questions before you go to your fucking Sally field meeting and
you're going to go to a meeting this week and all that.
Hold up a union site.
She made a sign.
It was so amazing.
Come to Brazil.
Hey Bill.
Hey Man.
I know.
I don't exactly know how it works,
but I think you are really talented and hilarious comic.
Well,
it's nice to know someone in this fucking side of the world.
Does.
My friends and I have seen most of your shows available online and we love it.
I believe you have a real market opportunity in Brazil.
Have you ever considered coming here anyways?
Keep up the good work.
A car in La.
Question Mark.
Hello.
Oh,
that's the next one though.
Sorry.
I thought that was him signing off.
I'm so dumb.
Um,
well yeah,
I mean I would go to Brazil.
Yeah,
I didn't say I was taking you.
There you go.
Now you go,
you go,
you go to Brazil.
You deserve it.
You,
you're so fucking,
you know,
abused in this country.
You poor women.
I mean Jesus Christ and be all this stuff that we do to you.
It's just got to,
it's got to be horrible living in your four bedroom,
garrison,
colonials having the list.
How do you do it?
How about where Marty,
how are you American women's do it.
How do you fucking handle?
Well,
it's how you,
it's devastating.
It's not easy.
Bed Bath and beyond every fucking 20 feet bed bath and beyond and really
Nichey,
a buffalo wild wings,
you know it is.
You guys love going in there buying shit.
I also like buffalo lab wings.
I know you do you like anything that costs money.
All
car in La end of that question is just if you're going to come to Brazil,
they just look,
this is how it happens in here.
This is how it happens.
They say and then somebody else says,
yeah,
I've got,
you know I've gone down there for one of the grand prixs.
Damn a grand Prix that and now what about carnival?
I'm not going to go down there watching everybody shaking their asses.
Oh really?
Cause you would have just such a hard time watching a bunch of hot Brazilian
women because exactly it again shaking their asses.
I would have a hard time.
I have a very hard time.
I'd be standing like Ron Burgundy,
my fucking slacks.
Erection.
I don't want to do.
I would,
oh fuck all right.
Car in La.
Hello Billy biceps.
No,
I never got into that whole fucking thing going in some fucking,
you know,
do go to Amsterdam.
You can walk into a physical fucking whore in the window.
I don't think carnival is like that.
It's just,
it's like everyone's like dancing and celebrating.
Yeah.
Walking wrong with their asses hanging out.
It's not like going into the red light district in Amsterdam though.
As far as I can tell.
Brazil is like,
what?
What?
What's like your capital there?
Rio Is it though?
I have no idea.
But from what I've heard from my friends,
it's one big red light districts,
but I guess that's just where they weren't.
Your friends were animals and they just went there for the,
we know what,
that's,
that's something different.
They weren't there to experience the culture,
the legality that are afforded to women who aren't allowed to podcast before you
got here.
Right.
Alright.
Billy biceps,
really,
really fucking grandmother hubs.
Now that I've kissed your ass a bit,
make sure you work on those triceps.
Those are the real beach muscles.
Like I go to the beach,
I got a question,
uh,
to throw your way.
Good Lord,
Dude.
That's what I figured,
you know,
get to it.
I had been working in the TV industry and I'm a [inaudible].
I have applied for a gig out there in la.
It wouldn't mind hearing a rant about what it is like to live out there.
I love biking everywhere.
The one with the pedals and everyone tells me that I move that if I move out
there,
I will need a car.
Ah,
bullshit.
But for real,
what are your thoughts?
I like electric.
I liked electric cars.
Is that practical?
Thanks for an average podcast at best.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Oh,
Jesus.
All right.
Hang on a sec.
I can't blow my nose and the mic.
Oh yeah.
Got All of that one,
Carlos.
Um,
you know what,
Nia,
you think he can do better?
Huh?
You think you can find a better balding,
fat freckled redhead.
You go out and you go through,
I don't know why you keep saying that.
You know,
you fucking see this.
Look at that.
You look great.
You know something near,
you're not helping me.
Classic comedian and response.
No,
you're not helping me.
I don't take a compliment.
Oh look random saying fuck right now to stay in the self loathing space.
Bullshit.
If you don't look good,
I don't tell you.
You look good.
You know,
if you noticed in 2009 I didn't say a fucking thing.
All right.
Uh,
yeah,
you can bike everywhere,
but it's a really dangerous,
there's a lot of frosted bicycles out here.
Um,
and now there's this weird thing where they just drew a bicycle in the middle of
the street.
Um,
and all the people on bikes go see that's a bike lane.
It isn't.
What it is is you get money from the federal government if you just spray paint
and bike on the street.
The,
yeah,
that's why they do it.
It doesn't really feel like it's always a proper lane.
It's just like a little section on to this,
not a lane.
They put it,
they put it like a third of the way out into the road and then these people in
bicycles are like,
I have a right to be out there.
And it's like,
of course you do.
Absolutely.
But when there's a car behind you just get over to the right and let us get past
this.
Such fucking assholes.
They go out there and they dress like they're in a bike race and they won't get
the fuck out of the way.
So don't be one of those guys.
And then what happens is if they get hit,
it's a fucking tragedy.
It's like,
no,
you're a moron who's riding a bicycle.
Like I stopped riding a motorcycle out here.
It was insane to be on a motorcycle and I'm going as fast as fucking cars.
Now you're going to be out there on a bicycle,
which is basically a motorcycle without a motor.
Yeah,
you're out of your mind.
You can definitely bike out here.
People bike,
all the New York City.
You can.
New York City is incredible.
Maybe don't rely on in your biking to and from work and stuff.
And you come out here.
Now what you have to do is you,
you gotta go down side streets.
You gotta,
you gotta you gotta figure out a way to serpentine.
But I would not drive,
go down sunset or Santa Monica or Melrose.
Beverley all the main ones.
Highland Labrea,
uh,
co Langa.
Uh,
Fairfax,
crescent heights,
La Cienega,
Doh,
Haney.
Tell him how wonderful it is to live out here.
Third Avenue,
Wilshire,
third street.
Third Street.
There you go.
Not that I'm talking about Santa Monica,
Third Street.
Those avenues out there.
Third Street,
like third street promenade.
They're super relevant.
Yeah.
Not the third avenue down the way here.
It's 30 to happen.
Okay.
It isn't,
I don't know,
just talk to them about how great this love out here.
That's great.
Uh,
we're running on a water baby seals washing up onto the shore because the oceans
are fished out.
It did kind of rain today.
I think maybe it got real cloudy,
overcast.
It's very overcast and see that's really a half or an ex machina today.
What is that?
The movie that I want the robot movie about the robot?
Yeah.
That mad or Mad Max.
One or the other or both?
Both movies.
Starring women.
God knows you guys will complain as so,
yeah.
But the trailer when he had a penis to be bigger,
um,
I'd just like breaking your fucking balls because everybody just sits there
going,
oh my God.
Everything you say is still valid.
Did you talk to them about the electric car?
Cause I know you've been wearing it.
Getting Electric car,
a Tesla.
So expensive though.
No.
Um,
I don't know.
We uh,
super expensive.
No.
Um,
well there's two tests was as like the,
the,
the s type that has a one electric motor and that's uh,
moves the rear wheels like the old days.
And now they have the new one,
I forget what it's called,
but that has two motors,
one for the front and one for the back of what's amazing about electric power
from what I've,
I've been looking is that um,
the torque is instantaneous or however you say it,
like 691 pounds of Torque at zero rpm.
Like immediately.
I think that's why I can't have a transmission because it would rip the fucking
gears right out of it.
But then I don't understand how it,
I don't,
I've never seen the inner workings of it.
So how does it turn the wheels and not fucking,
you know,
rip those things to shreds on the website.
They have all these diagrams and videos and stuff that is,
oh I gotta I gotta look at it.
It's amazing.
You can at this point you can drive across the country with the one that has two
motors because you're going to drive it like a maniac.
Yeah.
Get like 150 miles before you got to uh,
you know,
recharge it and then the,
the s when you get like 200 something or whatever,
but all I know is,
you know,
the average person,
you're not going on a fucking road trip.
I mean 150 miles for a lot of people,
it's like three,
four days of work.
You come home every day,
you charge it like a cell phone and then you never have to go to a gas station
again.
And right now the golden age of electric cars,
so the recharging is free.
But you know,
eventually that's not going to be frequent issue.
I have though,
when I was looking at the website,
they have a map because you can put in your zip code and it'll tell you where
all the charging stations are.
And like they're all at hotels and it's like they're for hotel guests only.
Like there's one car you'll,
you'll have one at your house too.
Um,
right.
Well that makes sense.
Yeah.
Then she sees people down the street with their thing plugged in and they have
them at the mall,
like all the malls and everything like that.
They've got 'em everywhere.
So I don't think it's impractical.
No,
not at all.
Lee.
They're popping up like a multiplying.
Um,
but uh,
everybody I know that has one.
Everybody that doesn't have one is nervous about getting way.
Like,
oh my God,
what if it just shuts off?
It I could have hung out at,
but everybody know that it has one.
It says they fucking ear to ear grin.
Who has one that,
you know,
I want to ride in one.
I want to see what it's like.
A buddy of mine that plays drums has one.
Uh,
another buddy of mine in comedian has one.
Okay.
Am I going to say what?
I'll tell you afterwards,
but,
okay.
I've driven one in,
it was,
I just drove the one that has the motor in the back was the fastest fucking car
I ever drove.
It was sick.
You just step on it and it just ended the seat.
Hmm.
Flying.
It's amazing.
The only thing,
the only thing I didn't like though is the center console.
Like on the dashboard,
it's like this,
it's this huge,
yeah.
Supersize
I pay,
it's very,
as,
I feel like it would be really distracting.
I would want to shade to pull down on it.
And it's like,
you can go online.
It's like,
but why do you,
why do you need to be doing that?
I don't want to driving anything.
You use it for like the radio and constantly sending you out.
Like you get in the car and then they'd like just beam you updates.
Yeah.
Update.
That's distracting.
That's not,
no,
no.
You get there and it's just updated,
right.
Oh,
this is cool.
okay.
Do you know they have a thing where the new,
uh,
you know,
while the new cars is suspension,
like the Corvettes and stuff,
you can have like,
you know,
regular suspension,
sports,
suspension,
supersport,
whatever.
Fuck you want to call it.
They have sports suspension and then their next one is just called insane.
It's kind of stupid,
but I actually Kinda like it.
Okay.
Um,
all right.
What am I going here?
Jesus.
Did you watch any of the Cavaliers game?
Do you know that?
I didn't.
Oh my God.
Everybody in the Cavaliers limping around like they're playing soccer,
making all these faces and shit.
I don't understand.
You barely step on a guy's toe and you see a mountain of a man just crumple to
his knees and then he wins the game.
And then Lebron immediately is like,
oh,
I'll camera's on me,
let me crumpled down to the floor.
And then he said this shit where they go,
ah,
you know,
how was the game?
Whatever.
He goes,
he's like,
well,
if I'm ready to be a leader of this team,
even if I'm hurt,
I need to step up.
It's like a,
you writing what they're supposed to be saying on sports center is really good
at meeting.
He really isn't.
That's how he got in trouble the first time I'm taking my talents to south
beach.
But these kids today,
they all grew up on fucking,
yeah,
they all grew up on sports and so they speak in sound bites and then the fucking
the animals on sports centers just repeating them to back in the day.
Nobody ever fucking said Shit like that.
Moses Malone,
you fucking had 90 rebounds and 50 points out.
Well how'd you do that?
And he's like,
I just goes to the rack.
That's it.
Larry.
You guys lost by 20?
What happened?
Yeah,
we played like a bunch of sissies.
That was it.
I was joking about that with law.
Had,
if he said that today,
he'd have to fucking go to a stop calling people sissies.net and apologize to,
what is your comments on Larry Bird's hateful statements?
Um,
all right,
so,
uh,
yeah,
I would get elected.
There's a bunch of [inaudible] the Chevy Vault.
There's a bunch of things.
If you want to get something like that.
Um,
but I think you'll really get into cars out here cause you live in them.
speaking of which,
I get my truck back tomorrow.
So what was going on was the,
uh,
there was a spring on the clutch that was touching the exhaust,
so that was the only problem.
Thank God.
So there's nothing wrong with the or anything in the transmission.
All right.
Oh,
I'm,
I might near if any point if you want to fucking walk out your asshole.
All right.
Baseball season bill,
is it me or is baseball in a Rut?
There's nothing exciting going on.
No great pitching performances.
No exceptional bats that you check out any sox games when you were back in
Boston.
Um,
I can address all of that.
You probably came of age during the steroid era.
Um,
I'm actually loving it.
I think baseball is back to the way it should be.
I love that Casey born,
it was a,
you don't like any sports.
I feel like baseball is especially,
I dunno.
It just can be and it doesn't,
yeah,
it doesn't appeal to you.
I guess,
I don't know.
May is that lame though.
I mean as baseball really an amazing sport.
I'm not giving it enough of a chance because I feel like basketball games,
I like to go to hockey games maybe cause it's this constantly fast paced.
This balls and play action goals and play.
Yeah.
Okay.
Maybe that's it.
Yeah.
You got to settle into a,
you got to settle into baseball and once you understand a little more what's
going on,
it's like cricket.
I thought crikey.
It was the dumbest thing I ever saw.
And then when I started learning some of the rules,
it's actually really kind of cool what happened if it's,
you know,
some sports just aren't for you.
Like for the life of me,
I sat down and after everything was done,
but when you came home last night you like,
why are you watching the rich kids of Beverly Hills?
Yeah.
It was because the basketball was done,
the baseball was done in,
the hockey was done and I put on some soccer or whatever,
football and uh,
I tried watching it.
Of course I put it on and there's some guy laying on the ground crying and
everybody's sitting there and oh,
you know,
flapping their arms around like the biggest tragedy just fucking happened.
And I just,
it just bores me to tears.
I love MMA.
That's Mike my favorite sport at the moment.
Okay.
I liked that too.
All right.
So whatever.
Okay.
Um,
also I want to say that despite you getting shit for sticking up for Brady,
you always really,
you're always really kind to most teams when they,
when you congratulate teams that beat your teams.
I don't know why you get so much shit.
Are you allowed to hate the Canadians in Alabama or whichever team it is down
there?
You Trash?
Uh,
thanks for uh,
for the laughs.
Oh,
I'm glad somebody fucking notice.
Like I didn't trash the Canadians too much for fucking illusion.
How could I,
we didn't even make the playoffs.
Um,
but uh,
I got to tell you that Tom Brady suspension is a fucking tragedy.
Oh.
And all the people that spoke up,
John Elway,
Google,
you know,
you got to follow the rules.
Really,
John Elway.
Like when you get drafted,
you fucking show up.
He didn't,
the guy gets drafted.
He goes,
oh,
I'm not gonna play with the colts.
The colts suck.
Trade me,
John.
That's not how it works.
Well,
fuck it.
Then I'm going to go play baseball.
All right,
John.
Okay.
That guy came in breaking fucking rules and he's going to turn around and say
that shit half got fuck all of these fucking people.
It's ridiculous.
Fucking NFL doesn't even pay taxes for God.
Damn.
70 fucking years.
Okay.
Your nonprofit.
Oh my God.
The fucking horse.
Shit.
Yeah.
For Games near the guy dropped the,
punched a woman in a head get fucking two games until the video got out.
They're like,
oh wait a minute.
We mean we don't tolerate that here.
All right.
Worst pickup line m
or smelled that one.
Yeah,
that one you respond to.
Right?
Cause that involved the lady.
God,
you're selfish.
Uh,
worst pickup line ever.
Bill heard you talking about bad pickup lines.
Me and my friends do this all the time.
One night we were trying to think of the worst pickup lines to open up with.
To a girl with dude,
that's some of the funnest nights you have.
I have.
It's just saying the worst shit.
Just watching you guys for you guys.
Yeah.
It's not about you.
No.
Why are you saying to say it to each other then listen,
Nia,
if you fucking told me not to involve us in your fucking dumb,
you're dumb.
Or who to cool with the words [inaudible] ever low people areas like why don't
you just do it for each other?
Why do you have to bring us into it?
Yeah.
If you did that,
something like that to guys with your lady friends there.
I would think it was funny.
If you weigh out,
if you just start fucking with guys,
it'd be funny.
I Dunno.
Maybe.
Yeah,
I don't know.
I have the name of that and tried to throw out lines to anybody in a bar and
fucking 11 years,
so maybe I'm a little out rockness worst pickup line ever.
All right.
Blah,
blah blah blah.
Sorry.
Yeah,
you want to leave on this one?
Cause it's so fucking annoying.
All right.
What night
am already annoyed by the question?
I don't even know what it is.
But go on.
What night
we're trying.
He said he sent us on a cell phone.
We were trying to think of the worst pickup line.
So put up to a girl and trying to be as creepy as possible.
Stumbled onto approaching a girl and opening up with the line of,
so how old were you when you got your period?
Oh Jesus Christ.
Why you sound like a fucking pedophile.
You know why?
So how old were you when you got your period?
What?
I can explain it in one or two word.
Explain it to words.
Appointment short jackets.
Now apocalypse now is a horror.
What is the,
what does this do?
What does the rest of this jackass?
So this is like,
this is like a 20 year,
I hope to God.
This is like a 20 year old.
Should I try it for a second?
And not a man in his thirties that knows about it.
I don't know
this is,
but I love him because he's fucking annoying you all right.
This is as this did this as a goof with force different strange woman.
Oh after I set it to a few of the girls I knew first as a joke of course and
something surprising happened.
They started telling me about it unfazed by the creepy inquiry.
It's almost like they've been waiting to talk about it.
Oh yeah.
We are just waiting forever to talk to some strange ass hole in a bar about the
first time we got our period.
Are you fucking insane and who are you talking to?
Drunk sorority bitches.
They don't count.
Sorry.
Okay,
here yelling at this man's just sharing his experience.
Sorry.
Ha Ha.
He says,
yeah,
exactly.
I'm not saying you should actually use this as a pickup line,
but I will say I really thought you were seriously suggesting this.
Oh,
you got to go in here.
What?
I will say that it opened up a long conversation with four different girls.
I didn't know and even became friends with one of them.
I don't know what that means,
but it seems pretty surprising to me that they weren't completely creeped out.
I figured they'd be creeped out or leave or call the cops or something.
Anything but what actually happened?
A story qualifiers.
This line was delivered in a joking yet.
Interesting tone,
interested tone.
And these were some presumably trashy girls at one of the trashy is bars in
America,
uh,
parentheses from Indianapolis.
So don't try it on a girl at a bar at the plaza hotel.
This is more of a motel six bar Spooner,
Spooner.
He basically what?
He had a bar like confirm my point,
which was like,
no,
he dead news as bad as you're saying this.
Do you know what he did?
He wrote though.
It'd be like,
oh my God.
Actually I was my cam [inaudible] and I that I was like so all,
and it's like I feel really bad about myself,
but then like my mom that it's totally normal and it's like,
I can't believe you're even asking me this because most guys are just so grossed
out by it.
Can we make outlet?
Yeah.
Dummies.
Cause any grown woman.
All right.
Half a God damn fucking brand sell.
Even if you were like,
oh,
so no,
but seriously,
when did you get your period would look at you like the fucking immature Jack
Jackass more than that you are and walk away from your ass.
You know the fact that I'm even wasting my breath on answering this ridiculous
thing just goes to show you.
I was told this guy was getting a little ahead of myself.
Just don't really have anywhere to go after that.
All this guy did was he went out and he had a little bit of fun.
Well isn't that just sweet boys being boys?
A little,
a little rapscallion is it?
Oh get outta here.
You're scamp is it okay for us,
for boys to be boys?
Is it okay for us to do that?
So do you have a problem with that?
No.
Not at all.
A problem.
When girls be girls,
what happens to you guys?
Something horrible that we need to understand.
Apparently men ask this one was the first time that we had our a period.
Okay.
But let me ask you,
I just want to ask you guys a question I wanted to today.
So what did he learn in all of this?
Okay,
so fine.
All right,
I'll relax.
I relax.
He was just being silly and trying to be creepy and try to have a good time.
Fine.
But like,
so these women,
I'm sorry everybody there period.
But what did they actually say?
When did you actually learn anything about a woman's menstrual cycle?
Oh,
will you shut up?
Like they're supposed to learn something.
He's just fucking around God.
He ain't even write it.
Write it in then.
I'm just trying to understand the point because this is the point.
The point is is we go out and we have to try to fucking convince you guys to
have sex with us.
It's up to us to fucking come up with some sort of line and it's a fucking
terror of angel.
Would that his way of like trying to get somebody to have sex with him?
Know what I'm saying is the,
when you fucking coming out and your voice is changing and it's up to you to
initiate the thing,
it can be,
for a lot of guys,
it's a very intimidating thing.
So to get to the point in basically not giving a fuck.
This is like a standup comic who's no longer afraid of the crowd and can handle
himself and actually can dig a little bit of a hole,
no pun intended,
and maybe still be in the fucking game.
All right.
That's all these still here?
He's having a good fucking time.
Okay,
that's it.
Then he went into some shit,
a whole fucking thing,
and he's having fun.
Do you think he actually hooked up with these pigs?
Maybe he did.
Okay,
but if he did,
it's his dick in her fucking vagina,
so stay out of it.
Golly.
Wow.
Steve,
what the fuck?
He just having a little bit of fun here.
No,
I listen.
He just made a lot of good points.
I know.
So you don't got to go all Edith Wharton every fucking time a guy puts a smile
on his face.
Who is this yours?
Bell.
Edith Wharton's.
That lady.
You made the flag and the Afghan in the late 18 hundreds Nah,
she was married.
She didn't like to be fucking married and we had to read the stupid ass fucking
book in college and you know what?
It's dog.
She was a feature act at best.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Now you rubbed a lot of good points and I,
I rescind my eye or in the last one.
Okay,
we'll let you go if that means you're going to shut up.
That's exactly what
dollar shave club,
everybody you've heard me talking about,
dollar Shave club.com the company that delivers amazing raises for a few bucks.
I know razor that costs a few bucks.
Delivering a great shave seems too good to be true,
right?
But you really have to try the razors,
the dollar shave club.com razors.
We'll give you the most amazing shaves you've had in years.
All right?
Hey,
don't pay triple the price when you can get a fantastic shade delivered for just
a couple of dollars.
You'd have to be an idiot to keep overpaying if that's what you want to do.
God bless you.
All right?
Don't be fooled by the price.
These razors are legit and you will never go back.
Plus,
they've also got Dr Covey's easy shape.
Uh,
it's phenomenal.
If you're still using old fashioned shave foam.
You know what?
You're a loser and I feel bad for you.
Try Dollar Shave club.com/bird today to get started.
You'll wish you had done it sooner.
That's dollar shave club.com/berg.
What does it?
Nia
dollar shave.com/bar.
No dollar shave club.com/fail
uh,
legal zoom.
Are you the world's next world?
Famous entrepreneur?
Will neither am I.
That doesn't stop you from using legal zoom or maybe you just don't care about
fame.
You just want to help people.
Whatever your motivation,
if you're an innovator,
it's easy to launch your dream this month with legal zoom.com.
Uh,
incorporate or form an LLC to start Your Business,
registered your trademark to protect your products and services.
Apply for a patent to secure your invention.
Like all those wonderful women that event invented all that stuff over the past
decade,
legal zoom has helped more than a million people just like you turn their ideas
into reality.
So excuse me.
What's special about this month?
For a time?
For a limited time,
you can get a special savings on any trademark,
copyright,
or provisional patent application.
Go to legalzoom.com today to get started.
Uh,
they can even help you if you have a great idea,
but you're not sure where to begin.
Said it.
Not a law firm.
You can get advice from legalzoom's network of independent attorneys in most
states.
That means you can get the guidance you need to get your great idea off the
ground.
Don't forget to enter Burb,
but you are in the referral box at checkout this month for your special
discount,
legalzoom.com Promo Code Burr.
A legal help is here.
All righty.
There we go.
Jesus Christ and plates holdings.
It's going to hit the fucking house.
Well,
the,
I hope you enjoyed your time this week on the podcast.
It's been a long time.
Yeah.
Brow beating.
What are you talking about?
You own it last Thursday for like a second.
This is the longest I've been on and God,
is it ever enough?
All right.
Listen,
thank you God.
I was just saying,
I was,
I know.
I'm fucking with you.
Um,
all right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Thank you for everybody for listening.
Uh,
once again,
I will be down to the comedy store this Wednesday at eight 30,
hosting the all things comedy,
a network,
uh,
live standup show with a bunch of other comedians,
Neil Brennan,
Al Madrigal go to,
uh,
Ooh,
fuck a carb store's website.
Sorry.
They'll figure it out and figure out what's going on.
That's the podcast.
Uh,
my next big tour.
Why don't I give you that?
I don't have a name for this one.
I'm sorry to everybody,
but it's going to be a west coast tour.
A fuck in west coast.
Tor.
Just sit right back in the here.
That tails,
uh,
it's going to start off in Portland,
Oregon.
And uh,
then I go,
Eh,
you know,
it's beautiful.
Even like it.
Um,
I'm going,
I've always wanted to go to,
to,
or is it important than that?
Yeah.
I want to go to Portland.
It's supposed to be really be Oregon is known in Portland.
Portland is in Oregon.
Is that what you said?
Portland's no states.
Neither is Seattle and Chicago state or city.
Chicago.
Is that a state or a city?
It's a state.
No,
it's is any.
Oh Wow.
My God.
What?
I know I that would say that to be in Celtic,
Nashville state the city.
That's cause you watched the show.
That's true.
Love that show.
What's the Capitol of Buffalo?
The capitol of Buffalo.
Do you mean the capital of me or
what is it?
It begins with an a,
the capital of New York.
Wait,
it's um,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
You'll you lived there for 10 years.
Yeah.
Look at this.
You want to make the same amount an hours.
Be Unbelievable.
What is the capital of New York?
I really can't think of it right now.
My mind is completely drawing a blank.
Oh bunny.
Why Not Take Albany Capital Buffalo?
Did you fuck up?
I was trying to trip you up.
Oh,
okay.
Oh wait.
So look at your,
you're going to be in Portland,
Oregon on buffalo is anchored for Reno,
Nevada.
June 20th,
a Santa Rosa,
California.
June 9th and 19th.
I'll be in,
uh,
Sacramento for some reason.
I don't know.
There's database,
uh,
June 21st Santa Rosa,
June 22nd San Jose.
June 23rd Fresno.
Never to Fresno.
June 24th,
Bakersfield,
California.
June 25th,
Highland,
California.
Where is that?
Is that obviously near bakers in the inland empire.
Oh,
the IEE bitch.
Okay.
At the San Manuel Indian Bingo and casino and yes.
June 26 and 27 Vegas baby.
Yay.
At the Mirage.
Very excited.
Okay.
Tucson,
Arizona.
June 28th and then he's in Malia on July 22nd and July 23rd for the just for
laughs comedy festival.
And I'm working on a Toronto date,
uh,
in September.
And then I'm also trying to put together a bus Rono
six with my woes.
Do you know what I'm referencing?
A course not,
but it's,
we bill and tell him what I was just,
hey,
thanks for listening.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'll talk to you next week.
All right.